the way we designed houses in different
places makes for different solutions so
when you think about a house that's
going to be built in say suburban
Houston there are different inputs and
different requirements then if you're
building something and say an
industrializing nation architects have
to deal with that and therefore come up
with very different solutions for the
two for the two inhabitants you know
when you're dealing with some building
something in the United States and a
suburb you're thinking about how are we
gonna create a house that engages with
nature how are we gonna create a house
that uses less electricity instead of
more electricity and that is thermally
insulated so we're not bleeding heat all
over the place how are we gonna make a
happy space without taking up 8,000
square feet but rather build it in 2,500
square feet so it really becomes a
problem of excess and dealing with
excess in the developed world it's a
different equation when you're thinking
about the developing world frequently
there's a history and a tradition of
people getting in there and doing it
themselves so when you think about the
favelas that grew outside of cities like
Rio that's people realizing we don't
have anywhere to live we're just going
to go and start to jerry-rig solutions
and occupy spaces that otherwise weren't
occupied by the city that leads to other
architectural questions about how do we
make those stables so that even though
they're jerry-rigged they're safe in
case of storms or earthquakes and then
how do we take what's this very
naturally occurring ecosystem the social
ecosystem really tightly woven
interactions in these densely packed
places how do we make sure architecture
doesn't destroy that but rather enhances
it so how do we start to add public
spaces to a space that was only built
out of necessity where two parks go
where do people go see a show or hang
out and how do you do that safely and
economically the favela painting project
by Hassan Han is an amazing example of
using just paint to create an entirely
different urban
context so the favela is these
individual pieces I built a house I
built a house I built a house built
without regard for for law or for zoning
statutes what Hassan hyung did is come
in and take these individual pieces and
turn it into one single iconic form and
they just use paint to do that that
creates a different sense of place a
different icon for the city at large and
the sense of pride for the people who
live there you can point to that you can
take pictures of that and say that's
mine that belongs to my community it's
an amazingly innovative project